emanuelle is a professional musician
he's gay and HIV negative and that's how
he wanted to stay that is why he relies
on prep and antiviral medicine against
HIV infection it's mostly meant for the
high-risk group of sexually active gay
men until about two years ago I just
used condoms but there were always risky
situations I started to mistrust condoms
then I heard about prep and it really
sounded like a savior people used to pay
up to 800 euros a month or semi legally
order a cheaper generic version from
abroad but recent efforts by a cologne
pharmacist
drastically lowered the price to 50
euros a month
today over 60 pharmacies in Germany
offer the medicine Claudia Newhouse
store was one of the first in Berlin the
demand has been very high since October
we've had 200 to 230 patients here just
in this pharmacy and in Germany in
general it's around 1350 now for a
manual the pill changed his life as had
Sophia and Beckenham
rep took my constant fear away not only
in the bathroom but in everyday life it
helped me get emotionally intimate again
before every potential partner was also
a potential danger critics of the pill
are afraid that unprotected sex will
spread other sexually transmitted
diseases but people who take prep like a
manual get tested regularly for other
STDs possibly curbing the spread the
combination of better HIV treatment and
prep is having a significant impact
abroad
within yet still online lenders we are
now certain that prep can definitely
stop new infections and the UK new
infections have dropped significantly
and we can see the same in San Francisco
we can have these successes in Germany
as well for Emanuele prep is already a
success
it finally means freedom from the once
life-threatening HIV